the boo arc vagine oh the fusion dance
ultimate Gohan Majin Vegeta and Super
Saiyan 3 this is an arc that is packed
to bursting full of memorable moments
from the series introducing elements
that are still being used today however
when I went to my Twitter to ask the
question what is the worst Dragon Ball Z
arc the overwhelming majority claimed
the Buu arc now that was specifically
interesting because in spite of it
having the most numerous large set
pieces and fan favorite moments it was
still considered by the vast majority
the weakest arc of the series what are
you guys in youtube think cast your vote
in the top right
I've noticed that nowadays people are
scared to speak critically of Dragon
Ball Z for the most part with super
receiving the brunt of the criticism
because there isn't a nostalgia
associated with it and this was made all
too evident in the comments section
under my poll on Twitter so today I want
to shed some light on why the vast
majority of those who voted had issues
with the Buu section of the manga to
highlight fundamental flaws and to take
an honest in-depth look at the final arc
of Dragon Ball that was written and
illustrated by its creator Akira
Toriyama
[Applause]
[Music]
the most common complaint I've heard
made at the expense of the Buu saga is
that its run time tends to feel
excessively law typically in film TV or
writing this is primarily due to the
structure of the story not pacing itself
correctly in other words it's not
satisfying the three-act structure
so what's the three-act structure in
1979 Sid fields published his book
screenplay within which he managed to
popularize the three-act structure now
utilized in most Hollywood productions
today this divides the story into three
sections with two inciting incidents and
a halfway turning point before the
climax as an example of how this
structure works I'll explain it with
reference to one of the best paced arcs
and Dragon Ball the Frieza arc in apt 1
our main characters are established with
a clear goal in mind revive their
friends with the Dragon Balls on Namek
they embark on their quests and arrive
in time to witness Frieza and his men
slaughter a small namekian village with
remaining low and undetected being the
initial plan of action things quickly
changes Golan is compelled to give away
his position to save a small namekian
child called Dendy this acts as the
inciting incident and climax for act 1
during this same act Vegeta sets his own
goal arrives anomic and destroys a
soldier within the forces he had been
enlisted their old lives are now over
they are rebels working against the
forces of Frieza
at this time - Goku embarks on his own
journey to rendezvous with the group
with the goal of encountering Frieza
specifically Act two begins as all
parties try to gain the upper hand
through force and strategic meets
however at the halfway point there is a
turn of the tables with the arrival of
the ginyu force due to this Vegeta is
forced to join the main cast of
characters to come back this new threat
ultimately overwhelmed however by the
challenge Goku arrives and makes the
save however he was not ready as he
sustains considerable damage to his body
now out of commission goku isn't able to
help Gohan Crillon piccolo or Vegeta in
combating Frieza this leads nicely into
the crisis of act 2 Frieza being much
more of a monster than any of them could
have predicted Goku arrives on the scene
unable to prevent the death of Vegeta
Goku is still not ready
through intense battle and sheer
determination alone Goku manages to
survive long enough
against Frieza to charge a massive
spirit bomb colliding with the tyrant
the climax of Act two comes as Crillon
meets his death at the hands of Frieza
leading to Goku achieving a state of
being thought to have been a myth the
first super saiyan in over a thousand
years goku is now ready the climax of
act 3 sees goku finishes fight with
Frieza followed by plant nameks
destruction ending in a bank Frieza has
been defeated they have achieved their
goal everyone has returned to life all
is good once again there is little to no
wasted motion in this arc with every
instance serving as an important part of
the story one difference I did notice
was the length of the first act of the
freezer typically around 25% of the
story is set aside for such a section
however since this is an ongoing series
characters and motivations didn't need
to be established which ultimately saved
more time now let's take a look at how
the Buu saga is structured and compares
act 1 begins as the tournament is
brought to the forefront alongside the
return of Goku and the rest of the main
casts taking center stage a short term
goal is established prevent Majin boos
release there is an inciting incident
that leads to Vegeta blowing up a
stadium of people things have now
changed and he cannot go back from this
the climax of the first act is the
inevitable release of majin buu into the
world this is specifically different to
the Frieza arc of Z in that the inciting
incident takes place before the
overarching goal of the story is
established to stop majin buu the
beginning of act 2 sees Vegeta take
responsibility for his actions with the
heartfelt sacrifice as Goku is knocked
out his efforts are ineffective however
majin buu persists to buy time for a
contingency plan Goku reveals Super
Saiyan 3 to boo wood as a twist of the
midpoint
he has forcefully taken away to the
afterlife leading to the inciting crisis
and climax of the act
Buu kills everyone on earth things are
dire enter act 3 now fighting in the
afterlife Goku Vegeta and Hercule find
themselves struggling against a pure
evil Buu through tenacity and the clever
use of the Dragon Balls Buu is finally
defeated and the world has returned to
peace with Goku and Vegeta - have you
been given their lives back the most
glaring difference between Nanak's act
structure and booze is found in its
first act
to emic 17% of the story to provide a
set up with a goal and inciting incident
took both forty percent of the overall
run time you might have also noticed
that in my breakdown of the blue arcs
act structure I left out a considerable
amount of fighting events and
information and this is my reasoning for
what I think is in my opinion this arcs
biggest flaw the elephants I omitted are
not necessary to the story to help us
better explore this concept let's first
understand this quote from John Truby
screenwriting book the anatomy of story
he writes any character who's going to
drive the story has to grab and hold the
audience's attention at all times there
must be no dead time no treading water
no padding in the story in other words
the plot should move forward
incorporating no wasted motion with each
scene piece of dialogue and characters
servicing the arcs themes and Meredith
for example in Marvel's guardians of the
galaxy volume 1 the film begins as were
introduced to Peter quill too scared to
take his mother's hand in her dying
moments he flees outside only to be
abducted the first act is spent
introducing us to the supporting cast of
characters and establishes the goal of
the film culminating in the final act
achieving their goal through Peter
facing his lifelong regret learning how
to share pain what might have seemed
like an arbitrary addition to the film
at the beginning ultimately set the
foundation for the most emotionally
charged and cathartic moment of the
story's climax
there was no wasted motion story beats
happened for a reason to serve a purpose
even Peters alias star-lord has
significance a nickname given to him by
his mother communicating to us the
viewer that she meant so much to Peter
giving his characters goofy and
light-hearted demeanour an emotional
weight behind it now that's not to say
the Buu saga doesn't have emotional
weight behind it it most definitely does
and I will address that but it also has
more than a significant amount of
unnecessary story beats that don't serve
the story beats that while fun if
removed wouldn't have any noticeable
consequences to the arcs conclusion
Gotenks ultimate Gohan's achievement and
practice port are fusion and really
fusion in general do not serve the
narrative instead act like their own
mini stories that pause the main story
being told I wasn't
were looking back over this arc to find
that a concept as unique and interesting
and prolific as fusion didn't influence
or play a role in the story's climax or
narrative really if I was to remove it
or any of the other elements I just
mentioned the story makes just as much
sense as it did with them at the
beginning of this video I mentioned that
accompanist has a made toward the Buu
saga was it spacing and how it tends to
drag and this is primarily why one of
these inclusions are awesome the story
very much stops to accommodate them halt
in the forward progression of events
take any substantial element away from
the freezer arc and it wouldn't work you
need freezes henchmen you need the
Dragon Balls you need Vegeta you need
guru and you need the Super Saiyan
transformation now that said would
including Gohan schooling ultimate form
and the concept of fusion enriched the
lore of the series and give characters
that don't get screen time some exposure
yes but was their inclusion necessary
for the story
no now does that mean I don't want those
elements in the story no I want them to
be necessary to the story and this can
be achieved by making small changes to
it have the Delon Golan's relationship
matter perhaps Buu kills her and Gohan
couldn't stop it he's then forced to
contend with it being his fault that
she's gone to become stronger than ever
and to avenge her even fusion could be
integrated to Regina's Ark was about him
come with the terms with what he really
cares about to lighten up what if in
order to defeat Buu at the end he needed
to do the fusion dance with Goku
speaking of Vegeta
Vegeta is without reservation the best
written character in this entire section
by far his arc begins almost immediately
after he is introduced and but it's
ending has reached its conclusion with
almost no wasted motion much of the arcs
feeling of suspense and tension comes as
a result of the emotional weight Vegeta
brought to the story and once he
sacrifices himself almost halfway
through the emotional resonance of the
story doesn't come close to that until
the ending which again is thanks to
Vegeta on the flip side of that the
concept of majin buu was an interesting
one in some respects he is wildly
different to any other villain Toriyama
had made before him and the idea of
there being some internal conflict
inside of Buu was interested however he
was plagued by some obvious issues some
of which are connected to specifically
the design of his character majin buu
doesn't have much in the way of a
character or personality he reacts
pretty much the exact same way to
everyone
thus as a result he needed bobbity to
act as his mouthpiece who was in love
himself a somewhat annoying character
however I don't think that's necessarily
the reason his character had issues but
more of a symptom of a much larger
problem and that problem being majin buu
assumes many different character designs
and personalities throughout the arc as
a result we aren't given enough time to
connect to the character as well as we
might want to freeze and sell changed
throughout the show via transformation
but their personalities remain
consistent allowing us to identify them
as the same character if majin buu was
just an evil force of nature that is
something that can be worked with
however if during your story your main
villain changes personality demeanor and
outward appearance as regularly as
buddhas then you are faced with a real
issue of villain hot potato resulting in
a climax with a villain in reality we
just got introduced to a woman that also
inherits all of the responsibility for
the acts horrors if we look at the
beginning of the story and put it next
to its ending you would think it's an
entirely different story being told and
that's because it is with none of the
starting cast even present I think this
Eric would have worked much more
effectively if majin buu was a red
herring and Vegeta was the twist villain
of the arc ending as he ultimately comes
to his senses realizing he was wrong
before making the save to undo the chaos
he had wrought on the people he loved
this video has been in no uncertain
terms the most challenging essay I've
ever had to write
requiring me to revisit many of my books
rereading the manga and talking to fans
of the series of the topic the story of
the Buu saga is filled with some of the
most heartwarming awesome and tragic
moments in the series in isolation but
ultimately I think they are dragged down
by the unorganized and incoherent nature
of its narrative
I still enjoy the Buu saga but in my
view it is without question the weakest
arc in the original series from a
narrative structural point of view
despite having some of its most fun
elements Toriyama had a gift for
illustration composition and whimsical
storytelling however for whatever reason
might have befallen his last hands-on
addition to the series whether it be
circumstance exhaustion indifference or
any combination of the aforementioned
it's the unfortunate reality that the
Buu saga could have been so much better
and was in some respects a mishandled
mess thanks for watching
[Music]